all right solo hello everybody I am
sitting here with Sevilla king Sevilla
is a therapist
she has also a YouTube channel called a
quality existence and she's really been
diving into this whole problem of the
meaning crisis she's been talking about
genre Bakey about myself she had a
discussion with Paul van der clay so
she's really in the midst of things and
she's also trying to connect a lot of
the ideas that that were bringing up
with Robert Pierce ik who is the author
of zen and the art of motorcycle
maintenance um so a pretty famous book I
have not read it so I'm kind of
discovered discovering that that whole
area with Sevilla and so I'm yeah I'm
really looking forward to seeing her
insight and where we can get to in this
whole problem of the meaning crisis
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world well thank you Jonathan
I've I've really enjoyed your channel I
as many of us did I came through to this
through Jordan peterson and and I was
watching you know I was watching his
electricity for he became famous because
he just was touching on so many areas
that I was interested in and it was
helping me understand you know certain
psychological big psychological issues
understanding Carl Jung and there was
the meaning aspect of it and and this is
sort of when I was I had started to
really become interested in spirituality
my own spirituality and the way my
clients were using their spirituality
you know to deal with let's just say
mental health issues and other issues so
so I began in the arts and we may have a
similar experience because when I was in
art school some of the things you say
about you know being in art school and
being kind of but you know kind of
bulldoze by postmodern art that
certainly happened to me I was in I was
in art school in New York in the 80s so
that was a big deal then and and so I
was in the arts for a long time I was in
the antiques business art restoration
business and and then I found you know
that I needed I just found myself drawn
to psychology and and I wanted to be a
therapist so in my 40s I I switched
careers and so so what was happening is
as I moved along in my new profession
one major problem I found with my
clients was was a lack of connection to
what let's just savor Bakey calls the
real world and what Viktor Frankl calls
the noetic dimension and in in Eastern
philosophy and Zen you might call it the
observer and maybe
to relate to to your philosophy I think
it might be a lack of a significant
center if that makes sense and and I
guess so that's how I sort of
characterized the meaning crisis is
people were sort of looking for meaning
in the material world right and and so
that you know so in Jordan and in Jordan
he he did this thing where he he you
know kind of switched a focus of reality
onto meaning rather than than things
mm-hmm and this was just such a profound
thing for me to hear because it just
seemed like he says it just seemed to
line up with something I already knew
and so then I just that particular thing
at that time and it's not long ago that
I that I got involved in Robert Pearson
it was about the same time that I read
that book and it was just like wow this
is it you know this is this is someone
who is trying to identify as as you are
you know as you are doing the patterns
of the structure of reality or the
structure of reality on a metaphysical
level that is that is not materialistic
and and so and so I became very drawn to
to this and that's when you know you had
done the the metaphysics of Pepe Pope
but the video that I really loved that
you did was symbolic versus literal
meaning in the Bible and that really
kind of made me a ditsy to your channel
and and so I noticed you know with you
and with you know under the umbrella I
guess of Robert Pearson who's I was very
interested in Jordan at that time so I
was really focused on his work but I
kind of sort of segwayed into piercing
which is where I am now but but I
noticed that with you you have the
symbolic meaning structure and your
brother with his with his book and I
know you and him it's very related
Jordan Peterson has his maps rebel will
wisdom is reintroducing Ken Wilber who
has his quadrants
you know verb a key houses has
the an agog a and the connection to the
real world so it's so related and it
just seems like everyone is trying to
discover meaning on this new plane on
this non-materialistic plane and and and
like Paul said in the interview the
other day that the material the way the
materialistic way of looking at the view
is just about run out yeah and so and so
that's what I'm really compelled by yeah
I I totally I think that that's one of
the things that really attracted me to
Jordan as well the this one lecture he
gave early on I think was called reality
and the sacred or something yes yeah
that that he had sent that to me because
I had heard him on the radio and then he
had sent that lecture to me to say you
should watch this one and so I was
really blown away by and I think what's
what's amazing and what's really strong
about what he's doing and what's
happening now is it's not only that it's
not only that the materialistic world is
materialistic vision is running out is
that it's it's flipping on itself it's
kind of turning back over in order to
reveal the inevitability of meaning it's
like as we reach the
as we kind of exhaust this idea of the
flux around us as we kind of notice it
as it as it becomes clear that the world
is is so full of flux and meaning of
detail that at some point the
inevitability of the pattern comes back
because we realize no we need a framing
we need framing we need these frames in
order to even perceive reality or to
even engage with reality and like you
said this notion that we we perceive
meaning first you know we perceive
purpose first and then we can analyze it
and and give it a more kind of
materialistic frame but the first thing
we see is is purpose and so that to me
was really the key to help people you
know it's like to really because you
have to turn this screw this weird screw
that has been tight for I don't know
since the 50s are sick I don't know
since when maybe since the 19th century
to kind of you have to turn it and then
all of a sudden you see once it opens
and you can see it in people's eyes you
can see that they've changed their
perspective they've know
they realize okay oh that's what it
that's what it's all about this is what
we're talking about you know this is
this notion that the inevitability of
experience inevitability of the first
person all this stuff it's coming back
and it's not a question of subjective
versus objective which is the way it has
been framed to us you know in in the
past where there say this idea that
personal experience is subjective and
then there's this whole objective world
like no no no you there the objective
world needs a personal frame but in that
pertinent personal frame is is not
relative to each person it's an it's an
objective structure that oh that all of
humans you know have in their you know
in their psyche or in their being so the
structure of consciousness
yeah the structure of state and then the
structure of consciousness becomes
actually the pattern by which the world
exists yes and that opens up so much in
terms of understanding the story in
Genesis in terms of why its language why
its consciousness why it's it's a you
know the the knowledge of good and evil
why it's all these words that are
related to what we would call today
consciousness those are the words by
which we talk about creation itself
because it's it's a not analogous to how
we experience and encounter the world so
yeah to me it's like this whole
rediscovery is so fascinating it's
fascinating and isn't it fascinating how
these maps you know like yours in Jordan
sign up and then there's these other
maps that line up with that as well so
what you're saying about the structure
of consciousness it's it's got to be
true because it's showing up everywhere
yeah and so yes and it's an exciting
time and I think discussion with John
that's kind of going on and we're
probably gonna do some actually do some
events with with him and then Paul and
then I'm seeing huge pop in and so I'm
hoping there's other people like
Benjamin voice and all these other
people in the that are turning around
this whole question and so it's exciting
because it I it's it's like a weird
virtual community I guess mm-hmm
something like that yeah and I guess it
has to be because this is where we are
and and you know and and this is I mean
this this digital internet thing it's
not going away we have to we have to
integrate it in the best and
highest quality way as possible mm-hmm
and and that's I mean I'd like to talk
you know at one point in this discussion
about how one thing I think is amazing
that what you're doing is taking this
ancient way of seeing things it's
eternal way of seeing things and
integrating the new into it and there's
no other way to do it because this is
reality you know that that you within
your framework there's a place for
technology and there's a place for
science
because they are part of reality yeah
the ideas did not just be a reactionary
and resist to be a Luddite or all that
all that kind of stuff that you see but
rather I'd if if this is the pattern of
reality then all we're going through has
to also somehow fit in that pattern you
know and even even the stuff that that
is hostile let's say to the more
traditional worldview all of that that's
trying to eat at it it's also part of
the bigger pattern and we can see by
looking at the story is that it's we've
already talked about this we already
discussed the problem of of how a
worldview breaks apart what that looks
like what happens when it when that and
how does it come back how does it
resurrect or how does it come back to
life so you know it to me that's that's
the best way of doing it that's why I
always try and remember like the right
hand in the left hand in to yeah your
stand those two sides that you can't if
you emphasize one side too much you're
you're you're in deep problem that's one
of the things I like about during
Peterson right from the start
yes and I felt that his structure
encompassed a lot it encompassed a very
large field and so you you could you
could look at two sides and be able to
explain why those two sides exist you
know and you can criticize one side and
criticize the other and you can also see
the positive sides of one side and the
other so you're not you're not becoming
polemical in the same way that we're
seeing the politics today exactly so so
I it's interesting because I've looked
at so much of your of your content but a
lot
a lot of what you and Paul you know
there are things that you and Paul
discuss the other day that actually rose
to the surface as as points that I could
connect with piercing probably as well
as anything and let me I want to just
you know I had gone through the meadow
like an introduction and metaphysics of
quality in that second video I did so I
don't want to go into it too much
because it's there but but the
metaphysics of quality is a is a
philosophy that reintroduces value as as
the element you know like like in
subject to object and scientific and
materialistic there's no room for value
you know in the in the actual rational
framework what you say is no there is
because it's ensconced in this greater
value and I think and and that's very
similar to what Pearson would say he
would say that the metaphysical quality
is value creating the universe and and I
want to just briefly mention one thing
about his philosophy that I think that I
think makes it makes it a little bit
more apparent so so when when feed
recife dresses the character and zen and
the art of motorcycle maintenance and
what he is is the he's the original peer
sick before Pierce had had electroshock
therapy for what was diagnosed as
schizophrenia and and Pearson who's
really brilliant you know so so he's off
in this direction trying to unite trying
to do a lot of what we're talking about
here he's he's identified that there's
classic quality which is you know the
more rational the the mechanical the
rational and then there's romantic which
is aesthetics and so as he's trying to
you he realizes that if if you're just
looking at things in these polar
opposites like you're saying
polarization you're not going to get the
full picture you can you can explain
most of the world with the subject
object way of looking at things but
you're not going to explain these
ephemeral qualities that you have in
romantic quality so he makes a really
big breakthrough when he discovers the
mathematician plunk ra and ponk RA is is
where you know looking like we said now
there's all these facts and now even we
have even more because the internet
introduces just you know an explosion
effect and they and these facts will
present themselves and you don't know
which ones are right so say you're
working on something and you care about
this project but you don't know what the
next step is and you can't just observe
everything objectively and figure it out
you have to care you have to have this
essential state of wanting it to be
better
and so Pangkor a found that when he's
working on a mathematical problem the
right there's a there's what you would
say a quality detector in this is his
theory in pre intellectual awareness you
know before conscious like like
consciousness but unconscious yeah and
in that pre intellectual awareness
that's where that's where quality makes
itself known to you you don't actually
have a will you can't say I mean yeah
well let me go into it in a second but
in there the next quality step kind of
kind of presents itself and then that
comes into awareness so intuition I mean
it's it's this it's just this like it's
the click write.the aha you know it's
like a click it's the Oh hot yes but but
but even more than that it's like an
essential quality it's an eternal thing
that comes up to you you know it's it's
always present and it comes up to you in
that subliminal state and then you'll
detect the right facts there if you are
caring about it if that's what you want
you know you can't just like sit back
and wait for it and so so there's a
quote here the difference between a good
mechanic and a bad one like the
difference between a good mathematician
and a bad one is precisely the ability
to just select the good facts from the
bad ones on the basis of quality he has
to
CAIR this is an ability about which
formal traditional scientific method has
nothing to say it has you know it has no
no room for value yeah so so the last
part and this I think is the most
important is there's a metaphor in zen
and the art of motorcycle maintenance of
the train so there's a train that that
is known as knowledge and that and and
the train is classical knowledge it's
it's rational knowledge that's
represented by the engine and the
boxcars and everything that's in the
boxcars that's everything the sum total
of human experience plus your own
understanding of that everything you've
learned so far your innate biological
traits you're not going to see romantic
knowledge so if you look at the train
you're not going to see see the romantic
part so this is materialism but romantic
knowledge is the leading edge of the
Train and that's what's going to keep
the Train going and it's going to keep
the trend going on the track of quality
and without this ephemeral thing that
can't be measured by science you know
nothing's gonna work so this is the
stimulus quality is the stimulus and
what is valuable propels the train
forward so the romantic quality is the
leading edge of experience that keeps
the train on track the boxcars of the
collective memory of where the Train has
been and the leading edge tells us where
to go so the end that leading edge is
right in the moment so so the structure
of the future is selected pre
intellectually mmm-hmm and you could say
that pre intellectual selection is kind
of like what you were saying about God's
will because value is the predecessor of
structure not the other way around and
the manner and and this is what you said
the manner in which the infinite account
encounters the particular so that's that
pre intellectual awareness encountering
the next thing and that thing will will
specify into what's needed and like you
said it's going to look like it's our
will but it's really this quality
showing us what it is
mm-hmm it's interesting what's
interesting is that I'm I guess I'm I'm
interested in the or curious about the
fact that he uses the word romantic
[Music]
yeah just option number pre intellectual
in the sense of trance it's over the
it's actually the word in Enriquez news
which actually think like but it's
intellect in the sense of direct
intuition of what is yeah you know and
that's different from the kind of the
kind of wispy feeling that you get in
the in the what I notice to be kind of
the romantic sense of this this kind of
sentimental urban flow
all of that is is act that would I would
quote put that below the thought
rational so you have I mean this is like
this is like traditional Christian but
you know ontology so yeah the noose
which is which is above then you have
the thoughts the we'll all of this kind
of the thing that we consider
consciousness would be below that and
then below that you would have the
desiring quality and the irascible
quality so that all the emotions all the
all their poles all of that would be
kind of this bubbling this bubbling
thing underneath you know so so in in a
way there's the unconscious within
normal psychology it was almost like the
unconscious would be this below thing
but then you have super kind of super
consciousness which is not I don't see
your framed a lot in modern modern way
of thinking it's not it's not the same
as the unconscious in the sense of these
these secret desires and all these
secret pulls that you have but it's it's
actually something above which is this
kind of intuitive grasp you can have ya
know if Percy talks about this this
difference or for him it's the same like
let's say the the romantic part of the
wispy kind of connection to to that
aspect to the belly to all that stuff is
different from the the top part let's
say I don't know it does make sense but
what he does is he changes the
terminology in the second book okay so
he changes it from a romantic quality to
dynamic quality and it changes classical
quality - static patterns okay so it's
this dynamic quality which is in the pre
intellectual and that like the Train
metaphor he uses
classic and romantic so I used it there
but in Lila he changes it to you know
the second book where he really you know
codifies the theory he changes it to
this dynamic quality and that's what was
going to be detected in the pre
intellectual and that dynamic quality
your in the static patterns mm-hmm you
know in the static patterns in the
metaphysics of quality very much are
like in your brothers book this this
here you know this this with with the
the inorganic on the bottom and then
it's biological then it's social and
then it's intellectual so it's it's
similar to that I mean not exactly the
same but it's a very similar
hierarchical structure and and so these
patterns and and they can be of any of
the for the dynamic quality acts on
these to transform them and so it's not
it's not romantic in that sense it's
it's dynamic in the sense that you have
things that are stable and and this is
the transformative agent let's just say
mmm-hmm interesting yeah I mean it's
interesting IIIi guess I should probably
at some point actually just read the
read the book I I was you know I I have
a I have a secret I have a secret thing
which is my my it's not a secret I guess
he will probably have figured it out by
now which is a certain a certain
aversion to this kind of California
Buddhism I call it yeah the book was
called zen and the art of motorcycle
mania huh you just turned me off right
away because no just just one more book
on that and so I I feel bad because it's
not it's obviously not an acceptable way
to judge a book and to judge a a
philosophy just by its title and because
I have this this weird thing about about
people using Buddhism to as a
deconstructive agent actually you know
like they're using the the foreign
something outside of their own
tradition culture - to wreck their own
thing you know it's a it's a it's a
normal move you know it was there the
Romans did the same you know the young
people would dress as barbarians as the
barbarians were at the gate you know -
coming in just like you something
the outside too kind of to demolish your
things so so hopefully so hopefully I
can get over that little thing the book
I think I think actually a lot of people
didn't read it for that reason
oh really and and and as you know in the
70s as people read it they realized wow
this isn't about sin at all mm-hmm it's
I mean it is you know but it's not it's
not what they thought it would be it's
really going back into Western
philosophy and figuring out where the
problem was
mm-hmm and kind of revivifying taking
that and using that to revivify our new
philosophy for the new age which i think
is is is similar to you know john Turvey
keeps going back and and to the ancient
greeks and looking for and and other
philosophers and looking for a direction
there and and if and it seems to me that
that Eastern Orthodoxy is is bringing
back an old practice into the modern age
so so there's a similarity there I think
yeah well for sure there's the I mean I
it's funny because what I'm saying has
absolutely nothing to do with actual
Buddhism like in texts I get a lot from
them and I you know I've read some some
some really you know if I read a series
of colons for example like I find them
extremely powerful and so in and and I
think it's obvious that it's inevitable
to notice their resemblance between
mindfulness and remembrance of God or
you know remembrance of sin in that you
find in in the hesychast ik practice
it's it's it's very similar so obviously
there is there are it's inevitable to
see that the resemblance is so yeah so
like I said a lot of it a lot of my a
lot of my reaction might not be found
you know it's it's more just a it's
almost like a social problem that and I
see rather than an actual philosophical
problem
and I'm sorry go ahead
no no no I I was gonna say so so how do
you see let's say so so in terms of
because I've seen you're doing a lot of
stuff on per se and then you're kind of
looking watching John's lectures
following Paul and myself and so it's
your how do you see these things kind of
coming together how do you see them
connecting in in the different way
because you you have your own very
particular perception about John's work
and my work and and all that so so maybe
you can talk a little bit about that for
people who also even people have and
watch the the video that you put out by
the way there are two videos that you
did trying to connect some of these
ideas together I'll probably put them in
the description those who want to get a
little bit more of that well I think
that my goal in all of this is to
actually be able to practice it in the
world you know not not just as a
therapist but my own personal personal
journey because I think we really as
you're saying as we come to the end of
this cycle as everything's kind of
falling apart is everything is so
superficial fragmented what are we going
to do to to read here that and I think
that that all of us you know you all of
us here in this corner are trying to do
that are trying to figure out a way a
philosophical way of being in the world
that can manage what's going on that can
manage all this fragmentation and I
think fragmentation is a beautiful way
of putting it and so you so so John is
looking at a variety of practices and
you and Paul already have established
Christian practices which you know work
work beautifully and I think that for me
it's sort of to follow to follow you and
to understand what you're doing sort of
gives me ideas of what is the next
direction and is the next direction
going to be something secular or is it
going to be something where I to in fact
turn around and start believing in God
and I know I don't mean to put
superficially as it sounds because
because the problem with this round is
the right word it's turning around
because the the problem with this is I
don't know and I don't know how you feel
about this I don't know if you can sort
of fake it till you make it I don't know
what happens in those terms because it
seems to me that I've had this innate
sense that unless I've truly feel it
with the entirety of my being unless a
person feels it with the entirety of
their being it's it's somehow
counterfeit hmm well I I understand what
you're saying I think that if you one of
the this is a guess one of the problems
with Christianity in general is that you
also don't want to confuse the beginning
of the road and the end of the road
right it's if you could if you could
completely inhabit it with your entire
being then you would already be a saint
and so then then you know you'd be fine
so I think that we have to be careful
not to look to be to find illumination
before we just actually walk enter onto
the path of you know up at the bottom of
the mountain also but at the same time
you don't also want you to pretend in
the sense you don't want you to lie to
yourself which would not be not the
appropriate but there you know I think
that you might not need as much as you
think to kind of start the journey and
so what is your in terms of the notion
of maybe what is your a little tell me a
little bit of your story do you did you
have a religious upbringing or did you
grow up in a secular like do you grow up
secular or did you kind of move away
from a religious upbringing at some
point well my parents were pissed the
peléan and and we had lived we had lived
overseas during you know there's a lot
of transition in the late 60s early 70s
and that's when we had gone on a long
tour and and my parents were rather they
like the tradition
all aspects of being Episcopal miss
cavilleri the Episcopal Church when when
we came back they said that they were
really kind of jarred by how liberal it
had become you know the macrame and and
[Laughter]
and so I think that they kind of they
kind of pulled back from that and so I
I've started going back to the Episcopal
Church and and it's interesting the last
so so I sort of became interested about
maybe ten years ago I started saying you
know there's something in this for me
mm-hmm
maybe a little longer than that and so
I've recently I've been going back on
and off and I've gone to the Catholic
Church a little bit but but but it's
interesting the last time I went I had I
was so full of your content in my head
because I was preparing for this
interview that it took on a different
dimension to see it symbolically you
know to see to see that these that this
was these were the words will the way
things were phrase from these eternal
representations and then I talked to a
friend of mine who said well you know
it's just the same thing every week and
I said yes exactly and so so then what
how I mean what is your in terms of God
what is your where are you you guys like
what what is your what is holding you
back or what is pushing forward what is
what is the issue they say well and I'm
very compelled obviously by piercings
work and I guess I should talk for a
second about this is a split you know
where where were you dressed the the
protagonist finds the problem and where
he finds the problem is it's back in
Plato where where Plato separates reason
from emotion and before that you know
the pre-socratic
the highest value was was the good was
r8 a was excellence was quality and this
is such a high thing and and so feeder
says this is what we have to go back to
we've had you know 2,400 years of
rationality which we needed because
because we had to figure out how to
manage nature so we don't die you know
basically and now we've exhausted the
utility that we know how to do all this
stuff and now we're kind of empty you
know the meaning crisis and and so so
that r8a that excellence that quality is
is you could say that that's the bottom
in itself in piercings work mm-hmm
or you could say that that's informed by
god mmm
you know you could say underneath that
on another level is God who gives us
this quality who who gives us the
stimulus towards the better who who is
is allowing us to embody on earth his
his will let's just say and his will is
toward the good it's toward the better
it's always it's always improving it's
always progressing ultimately in the sum
total of things of course there ends at
the cycle right now but even now you
could say that like like like you said
at the beginning of this this is an
exciting time because amidst all this
chaos is the possibility for resurgence
which is a totally new metaphysics
mmm-hmm so I think so I think that's a
roundabout way of saying that in the
center the center of what I'm looking at
is it this RIT is that this quality is
that enough or do I believe that this
quality is informed by God mmm-hmm so it
sounds simple to say but when I'm
actually struggling with it it's really
hard yeah I mean yeah I can I can I
guess I can understand
that I think that the idea of the
importance of God is also to bring let's
say you have something like quality and
quantity for example like we can use
your your terminology you know you have
the essences and then you have
potentiality you can say it that way the
quality and quantity but you need you
need a way for those two things to kind
of I mean I could say you could say it
like that God is the manner in which you
understand that those two resolve into
one but that that they don't that there
isn't this this eternal opposite you
know and that's that's one of the
problems that Christianity is trying to
always deal with problem of the eternal
opposite you know that you see in
Gnosticism or you see in a lot of the
ancient religions that in fact reality
is reality actually has a common oneness
out of which the quality and quantity
come together and that's why that's also
why there's this resurrection because
without without without the non duality
you don't have it you can't how can you
understand resurrection because you have
let's say quality in quantity that start
to pull apart and then they that you
know it's things start to fragment and
the ideas go up into the heaven or
whatever you know they they they they
disincarnate you could say and then
things start to break apart and but then
how does it what's that what's the
what's the thing that that the mystery
that brings things back you know and
that's the mystery of the of non-duality
and so people don't realize that
Christian that Christianity is a non
dual religion in people it is a non do
religion God is non dual it's not there
is no duality between God and and and
the world God informs all of all of all
of the world that God is hidden in
manifestation we don't you know we don't
confuse God and and
station we don't say we're not pantheist
you know we don't don't say everything
is God but but we do believe that that
ultimately everything is in God is a way
to say it something like that and so
that to me that's the that's why and and
and and I guess you know there are non
dual religions that don't that won't
tend to personify or to to see the
person or to see the infinite impersonal
ways you could say something something
like that or you know that we'll sit
then when you talk people talk about
impersonal the idea that that that the
absolute is impersonal you see I mean
you see that in some in Buddhism as well
but but I I think that that's
problematic in the sense that we talked
about that you mentioned before that I
talked about with Paul which is that
there is a way in which God is
impersonal and super personal or
something like that
but God will always encounter us
personally yeah that the the place where
the infinite and the particular meet the
place within is going to be is going to
be an analogous to what we understand as
as personal and so that's why that's why
we also encounter God as God is personal
I'll also like because we are personal
and we are that we are the meaning
makers we are you know we are the
meaning and those who encounter meaning
we are persons and so there's that you
know all of that has to be part of the
of the infinite somehow and so that's
the image you know the you can't use
another image of God besides that always
understanding that God is beyond all
those images you you always have to when
we talk about God we say father when we
talk about God we say son you know when
we talk you know there's no other way to
talk about these these these realities
which are ultimately
joong-dal name and our word I don't know
if that I don't that make sense in the
term in the sense that if you if you
want to go to this thing if you want to
stop at quality you're gonna have that
problem which is how then how do you
deal with the opposition that you've set
up
I don't know how does he deal with it he
deals with it it's it's it's again this
dynamic quality which unites the two
opposites because because let me give an
analogy of how it actually plays out in
the book so so you have a Prague so you
have a problem let's say it's something
with the motorcycle mm-hmm and so you
see the problem but but it's not it's
not the the non-dual you know is the the
quality and the item and and your
relationship with the item has to change
has to update constantly so your so
quality is helping you do that so you
can actually fix with that and that
means that it's not just an objective
piece of metal becomes you become
involved with it there's a communion
between you and the motorcycle and I
guess we're making might call this the
flow state it's where you are in
communion with the physical world and
you're improving it and you're informed
by this this desire let's say God's will
for the for the good I do think that
there is something maybe maybe the
dynamic quality is is a representation
of God or Christ I have I have also a
difficulty understanding in your
philosophy what exactly is the
difference between sounds so so silly
and I'm sorry to ask this question but
what is the difference in your
philosophy between God and Christ well
God yeah yeah yeah obviously the the
idea is that this is the career this is
really the Christian Way of
understanding so there is something
which is there is the uncreated you
could say the the D that which is
without origin that which is D for all
and beyond all right and so that's God
and we say father right because father
is the origin now Christ or the logos
the the the thing that that makes
crochet
so specific is that what would we say is
that there so this this thing that was
something obviously these are all words
that which transcends all which is the
absolute or the infinite it it manifests
itself it has a an expression that
expression is is the the names of the is
that which creates the world and so the
difference between Christianity and a
lot of other kind of new platonic
religions that came about in the around
that the same time as Christianity is
that the expression of the infinite is
is one with the infinite that is the
logos is fully divine there it's there
is it not a lower state of being it's
not a lower it's not lower in the in the
hierarchy and so what that does is it is
it does it is it eliminates the problem
of the notion that as that the hierarchy
of being is is necessarily it's a moral
hierarchy because you see that in a lot
of Gnosticism and a lot of the ideas
it's you know or in a social hierarchy
which is that the idea that the king is
somehow good and the peasant is bad
because he's lower on the on that
hierarchy whereas what christianity does
is that it because the the divine logos
is fully God is it like one step lower
that means that the expression the
expression of the infinite fills the
whole of everything and is and so
everything part it everything ultimately
can participate in the life of God
because there isn't that moral hierarchy
of being although there is a there is a
there are hierarchies of being but but
God fills all of them and so that's the
idea so there is no difference between
the logos and the Father there's a
difference in the sense that there to
that one is the absolute infant one
the expression of the infinite and and
they're different in the sense that
they're not but they're also of the same
nature that's all we have where they use
their they're fully uncreated they're
both are uncreated so that's the way
that's kind the way to understand and
then when you understand Christ as the
person Jesus Christ in history obviously
there's a there's a there's a there's a
specification but the notion is that
that's part of the process of the
filling and so you could say something
like that Jesus Christ is the fullest of
that filling and so so so Jesus Christ
gives us the full image of the the the
way that the world is in God and and the
full reality of how the world is in God
and so that's that's kind of how we see
that's how Christians would kind of
would kind of present it and so when you
look at the story of Christ
you see in his story and it has to be a
story because it's so weird it's so it's
the non-duality part is so difficult to
express in terms of categories that you
have to see it in the story of a person
this incarnate person so that you can
see the the strangeness of something
like the crucifixion into that mystery
is extremely difficult because it it
it's I keep saying it because it fills
the whole world it's both the highest
and the lowest at the same time yeah on
the cross Christ is the king and the and
the the the the scapegoat at the same
time yeah filling that whole thing so
that's that's the way that Christians
would present I don't know if that makes
sense to you know it does make sense in
it and I think what I'm thinking at this
moment is that I think piercings you
know the metaphysical quality kind of
it's it's parallel to this because it
describes the process this process of
incarnation let's say because because
dynamic quality creates the universe and
it's within everything so so quality is
is and it's not just people with a pre
intellectual awareness
this creation this create creative
processes all the way down to the you
know the smallest Clark you could say
that everything is directed towards the
good and one way to characterize the
good in the metaphysical quality is
towards freedom towards more agency
towards more space so as you go up the
hierarchy to the intellectual you are
closer to the good which is which is
similar to God in the sense that it's
it's more limitless mm-hmm so as so
there is a moral element in the
metaphysics apology in in the sense that
that intellectual is a is higher than
organic in the sense that if there comes
a time where you have to sacrifice one
for the other you would sacrifice the
lower because in the higher is where the
progress is is where the direction
towards towards God is the intellect
let's say in this but at the same time
everything works together so in another
way one isn't better than the other they
all need each other you know the
inorganic supports the biological which
supports and and then and the intellect
comes down and informs how we see these
things so so there's a dynamic going on
in that regard too so so there's some
similarity there except for the fact
that except for this moral progression
which intellect is up at the top mm-hmm
so so but I think the process itself to
me sounds very similar and when piercing
discovered this he felt like it was a
Trinity he felt like this this dynamic
quality is what United the cause the the
study again which we need aesthetic and
I mean the classic in the romantic which
which put together the subjects and
objects mm-hmm which made subsequent
objects able to be in communion with
each other rather than separate right
right hmm interesting and so did he ever
like did gearstick
ever talk about because I imagine he's a
westerner so he probably had some
contact with Christianity
I did it he tried to formulate his ideas
in relation to Christianity or was he
always kind of in the I guess he was in
it was in the 60s and 70s so that might
have not been the best thing to do for
him well I don't he wasn't I don't think
he was a Christian per se I think he was
more his his love was Western philosophy
mm-hmm so he was very much you know for
a long time he thought that rationality
and reason was all there was in fact the
last chapter I just did in the reading
of the book is where he he is so married
to the idea of reason and truth being
the ultimate that he's defending it
fanatically and in the wings is
something telling him no this isn't the
ultimate and what he does at one point
he does where he falls apart at and a
couple of times he falls apart one very
much so when he discovers that the the
this split in in Greek philosophy that
that they valued truth over over over
quality that really meant that is where
his madness begins but but during the
before that he goes to Indian studies
for a couple of years and tries to
integrate Eastern philosophy he has a
really hard time doing it because he
can't get out of the Western rational
mind mm-hmm so so a lot of what he was
trying to do is have a totality that can
you know metaphysics that can that can
be used in any situation in any culture
and then that's that's it's it's more
profound than that but I don't know how
to describe it differently it that was
the key you know the the infusion of the
Eastern philosophy was key to overcoming
the non duality but but it's not one or
the other it's a unification of both and
and I don't have the oh here this this
very difficult book by FSC North wrote
called the meeting of the
East in the West mm-hmm where this guy
was trying to do the same thing and this
guy said well no it's everything in the
universe is on a continuum like we begin
you know with a big bang and it goes all
the way to where we are now and and so
Pierce had used that continuum and with
quality he said again everything is
everything quality isn't everything and
quality creates everything mm-hmm if
that makes sense I mean it makes sense
it I mean it makes sense to me and I I
do think that I do I do believe that
different the word quality doesn't
doesn't bother me so much either because
it innit it has something similar to
what because it implies the in a certain
way to apply the essence of something
but it also implies the goodness of it
yeah just essence in the sense of a
concept sometimes you might think that
essence is just the concept of something
or the name you know just the name in a
neutral way but rather that quality also
includes the idea of it of a kind of
ultimate purpose or a you know a yeah
something which is which is more related
to to the good not just in a moral sense
but yeah kind of a bigger sense yeah
even in a pragmatic sense yeah exactly
no you're right in the sense that that's
what you like you said like fixing a
motorcycle not a moral question yeah but
if there is a and there is a goodness
there is something which makes it better
than then better than what it was
exactly
and so everything in the universe is you
know it's being informed by this this
notion of the better and there's
interesting if we're you know Jordan
Peterson used this neuroscientist to
explain this you know his map of the
going towards the better yok panksepp
who has the seeking system that every
that every that you certainly see in
anything biological and certainly in
human beings that you're always looking
for what is going to solve the problem
looking for the better so even in that
you see the same the same pattern that
directedness towards towards the good
yeah but there's something for sure in
the modern world let's say that has I
don't know if he deals with this at all
because it's funny that he would choose
something like motorcycle repair and
because there is something which has
diverted it in my perception this of the
good into the material world like yeah
we have we have turned it complete or
the material world which mean we
understand the better and the good only
in terms of technical innovation in
terms of
making our life easier you know with
technical supplements we're in in a
platonic sense the good would not would
not be understood exactly in that way
but rather in an existential way I think
John Rebecca is a good way to talk about
these different modalities of being you
know the molality we talk about the
modality of having and versus the
modality of a being and those two we've
actually confused them today where we
think that you know the good is only in
making things better and you hear people
talk about it so inevitably as if it's
so inevitable you know how great our
world is because we have nice we have
greater things greater technologies you
know forgetting this whole other aspect
of of the good which is its transform a
transformation of the person and which
is why we have the meaning crisis
exactly yeah and I think I think John
frames that very very well you know and
in a way that is is it's understandable
to most people because everybody feels
it today we feel that goal because on
the one hand we do want more stuff and
on the other hand we we also know that
that stuff is not going to it's just not
going to do with what we wear it wigs
we're deluding ourselves some people are
completely deluding themselves ly
unaware but I think most of us are
somewhat unaware that that although I am
let's say and I am still I am gonna buy
this new gadget I also know that it's
not going to it's not going to give me
what I it's not going to solve my
problem that's it that's it make my
problem worse especially the whole cell
phone you know I've avoided having a
cell phone for ten years now now I got a
song I know like I it's just too
complicated you know it reads me and I'm
traveling I finally got a cell phone and
I'm like this is this thing gonna kill
me
and and like like Jonathan for Vicki
says you know it's so salient it it
takes those things that we it takes this
same mechanism that we actually use for
you know meaning and puts it there oh
yeah and what the actual symbolism
ya know powerful because you know people
don't realize I was for a while is
wondering why is it when they see people
on television that they that they all of
a sudden those people become special you
know and and I realize it's it's it's
not just this but one very simple aspect
is the very fact that screens actually
emit light that you're looking at a
person is emitting light to you that is
a glowing it's glowing that person is
glowing it's not at all the same as
looking at a person in the world where
they're reflecting light now if you look
at a screen on your telephone it's
actually emitting light to you I mean
can you imagine just it's like can you
imagine just how strong just very deep
deep your deep deep breaths
yes how strong it is that you could that
you could be looking at this these
machines that are emitting your meaning
to you in light yep which gives meaning
to us beat that it's like it's good you
can't hate that that is so that's me
that's brilliant
that's brilliant you know and the
YouTube thing has done the strange thing
where everybody now can do that and and
and even on YouTube where it's there's
no method there's no mechanism of
legitimacy you know there's no there's
there's no clear method of legitimacy
people can still go on YouTube make
videos and then people see you as a as a
celebrity now many people and they're
like oh I feel like I'm meeting a
celebrity I'm like but just because and
I know that's what it is that you're
looking at me on it's on the screen and
and my face is emitting light to you and
and so it's like it makes you feel like
this strange this strange encounter you
know I don't know it's just an insight
that I've had in I mean
brilliant inside but I've had that
strange experience where I you know even
someone that lets I'm you we're talking
like this on the screen then one day
I'll meet you or maybe I'll meet you and
and it'll be a strange moment you know
when I meet you or if I when I remember
meeting like Benjamin boys or yeah
people like that when I meet them in the
in the world it's like this weird moment
yeah where all of a sudden this person
is is different as a it's kind of
embodied you know and I realize just how
how strong the screen is just how
powerful it is well that was my
certainly my experience when I went so
Jordan Pederson entered the
meet-and-greet after oh you did do the
[Laughter]
radio at first and so it was a little
different it's the radio is not the same
cuz sounded sound on the sound is the
same you know you have the same
experience of sound someone on the radio
but the screen yeah the screen I know
how we're talking about haha it's it's
all part of the conversation that's
right so what is what would you say is
your next step in terms of cuz I know
you're doing the series on person saying
people can check it out on your
challenge on your channel but what are
the next what do you see as the next
steps for you in terms of exploring
these questions
well ongoing it's trying to figure out
how to use this right you know and the
reason I call it a quality existence is
because that's what I'm looking for I'm
looking for how to have a meaningful the
best possible life for myself for my
clients for the people I love you know
in the most genuine way and and going
through dialogues like this going
through you know muddling through it
which is what I'm doing I am by no means
an expert on piercing but but just being
you know being doing it in a community
like this is really helping I've had so
much good help from viewers who know a
lot more about it than me and and so
it's just progressing with that
progressing with understanding looking
at ways to implement in the world and I
want to this is a good segue because
yesterday when I was or the other day
when you did the when you did the
dialog with Paul van der clay there were
some things that came up for me that I
think are so useful for what I'm doing
mm-hmm and they don't necessarily
actually relate to piercing per se this
is this is more this is more what you're
doing although again I see I'm relating
all these together a crow mentality
mm-hmm I just really I really am drawn
to that idea because what you were
saying is that if you are oriented in
the world towards the good and you apply
this towards other people
this will deepen your experience of
other people whereas you can just be in
the superficial subject-object negative
or you can engage you know with people I
guess in communion would you say is that
the right word I think this is a good
way to see how so you're looking for
what you know you're using your quality
detector this you know you say okay my
problem now is I care about in the pr6
term I care about making this person
valuable I'm not going to you know go to
my base or instincts and just dismiss
them be negative about them I care to
make them valuable and then you know as
you're doing that the sub pre
intellectual awareness detection of
quality will help you see the quality
the good and the other percenter and
that I just love that I think that that
particular approach would be extremely
valuable for people who have a tendency
to go towards negativity maybe I can go
back to saying you know what you were
saying about you practice it and then it
becomes second nature so that would be
something that if you practice it would
you know really improve your view of the
world but it but you do have to get kind
of a hold on it you do have to have a
connection with the spiritual there with
the noetic with you know with that sense
in order to to implement that and that's
not what you said is that is actually an
example of when you talk about how
quality creates the world
yeah exactly yeah that's also a way
which you can understand it because we
know let's say that if you engage others
with that mindset if you engage others
in a manner in which you see Christ in
them or you know you you you see the
good in them then you're actually going
to transform them that's right that's
right yes it's not just going to do you
good
it's actually going to because people
are more malleable than we think people
are way more valuable than you think
and so by by by seeing in others that
they will also slightly tilt towards
that as well they there's a manner in
which you're also putting on them an
expectation which they may not have it
it's not that light seeing the good in
others isn't as as light as you think
it's actually it can be quite quite
heavy because you're also you're also
putting on the other person a you're
framing the other person and that person
then will also have a will inevitably
feel a desire to fill that frame no or a
get all it could be the opposite
sometimes that person will flee away
from that and make even worse you know
this is the whole problem of the Last
Judgement let's say you know whole
problem but there is that's interesting
there is a chance that that you will
also transform that person towards that
the highest version of themselves yes I
engage in with them that way by giving
them as Carl Rogers would say
unconditional positive regard giving
them a chance yeah
the other thing that I just there's
actually three elements the second one
is I noticed that your framing of let's
just say health and pathology correct me
if I'm wrong is pathology is
fragmentation and health is cohesion
mm-hmm so so I believe that this
the way to icy personality that makes
the most sense for me is is as divisions
between parts of self and that these
divisions can be very fragmented
especially and you know in cases of
trauma um I'm actually gonna show this
book this is the way we are by Frank
Putnam it's not a famous book but it's
absolutely brilliant and what it does is
it proves and this is the states that
we're born with as infants so it it
really is a scientific way of proving
that we are that that we have the
potentiality for fragmentation and we
have the potentiality for cohesion hmm
and and in you know in kids who are in
terrible circumstances they end up being
very fragmented in their adult life and
so to cure them is is to use methods to
cohere and that is I think which are you
know it's exactly the same pattern let's
just say it's a fractal of the greater
pattern that you're talking about yeah
is around the center you know you go you
it would that be right not like is the
antidote for fragmentation what would
you say that was in in the Christian no
but I think the word cohesion is the
right is the right way to understand it
love is another word for it in the sense
that it's a form of cohesion that
doesn't eliminate the particulars you
know so it's not that it's not that you
those different aspects of you different
personalities are different you know
it's not that they're bad in themselves
it's just the day and don't know each
other or that they forget each other yes
they forget their origin their their
higher self or they forget what's hot
what's above them and and if they
remember then they become connected and
they become proper expressions of of the
the person you know and the same with
all the desired it's the same with
desire you know that the church fathers
they don't they don't think that most of
the church fathers leave they don't
think that desire is bad they think
desire is good desire is inevitable and
by desire that you will actually also
heal yourself and you actually enter
into God is by desire but desiring the
good yeah exactly
the only
problems that the desires they have a
when they have a will of their own and
they they take over and we all feel it
everybody experiences that where some
desire will take over and you become
that desire for a moment you know and
then you usually remember afterwards
you're like okay so why did I eat that
second piece of cake I always use that
example is like what happened you know
but it's the same when you get a really
angry and you're like okay who was that
because you know of a sudden you fell
into this this mode of desiring mode and
and you you forgot yourself so so I
think that that's the way to to
understand it you know that the person
that the person has to unite within
themselves their different aspects and
then but then there's a cosmic aspect to
that where the prisoner also uniting the
whole world you know when we talk about
consciousness and that's the way the
world exists is we also do that for
everything yeah that's what the person
the human person is is this this place
where all things come together yeah but
that also has to happen in yourself so
memory is the is a way that memory and
attention the way that attention yeah
the way it's presented and I wanted to
say that attention is like that than
caring intercept yeah exactly yeah
that's the right way to see it yeah and
and so and one thing I want to say about
the fragmentation is you know just to go
back to trauma like often in kids who
have been really abused they don't like
one part of them won't have a memory of
the other yeah you know like invert
multiple personality just sort of the
worst case scenario you know that at the
end of the spectrum and so it's
interesting how that view in Christian
in the in the Christian world view
mirrors the worst pathology and human
people you know the fragmentation almost
we do yeah we all do because it's
deluded to think you know we're not
aware of your experience if you don't
realize it
yeah and that and that is scientifically
he you know this is the scientific proof
for that let's just say not that that's
the you know pinnacle of everything but
embedded within our worldview our
scientific tools like
that help us you know help us understand
I mean I know people very close to me
who who who have certain aspects of them
where sometimes they'll say something uh
and then you know if I remind them that
they said it they don't remember mm-hmm
is there not in there really none of the
same let's say memory state you're
saying certain things you just act like
just not in the same mode at that time
fascinating to notice and it's like it's
not it's not pathological in the sense
that functional like a functional person
but sometimes when you see it in others
then you can try to be attentive to
yourself and realize you know it's like
sometimes these moments where you you
lose you act you react a certain way
like party to want to impress other
people you know when you're acting a
certain way and then you go back home
and you're like like who is that what
happened you know who was I in that in
that moment very strange so you need
something to help you Co here again and
I like in Jordan Jordan Peterson when he
says it's an embodied sense of the truth
your Co hearing you're you're lining
yourself up you know mind and body and
so with what feels right with what it
feels like the truth and I think that
that is the the third element I want to
talk about in terms of things that would
really help people with mental health
problems is worship it's like the idea
of worship and I think am i right that
that that is going around as having a
center well I would say I mean you could
say that circle you can see worship as
circumambulation in that sense you can
oh I mean a good way to understand is
also high in terms of higher inches or
higher the idea is that what is it that
you put at the highest point and then
what is it that you're that you that you
turn toward any witch what is it that
you celebrate yeah
and celebration and worship are very
similar worship is more celebration
I guess separation is kind of this
circumambulation worship is really is
this recognizing the Highness of
something or just just recta seeing it
just talking about it you know doing all
these gestures
no bowing down all these things that we
do to lower yourself in front of this
higher thing all these things that we
that recognize that what is above all
what is above all and so it's it is an
or it is an orienting right is it all
the autumn orientation orientation yeah
and and and how to and I think
difficulty would be in this circumstance
how to reorient it toward the real high
not some subversion you know yeah and
that's the difference between idolatry
and and I mean in the Christian you know
the kind of Christian world that's the
difference between idolatry and true
worship but for but Christianity at
least traditional Christianity Orthodox
Christianity they don't oppose and I
think that's something that happens in
Protestantism is that they they want to
always oppose the highest and everything
below and so they'll say you know it's
like if you if you honor anything then
it's a form of idolatry that's not the
right way to see it what you're doing is
you're separating God from from
everything rather the best way to do it
is to have let's say a category which is
the highest of high which is worship and
then have a form of honoring for the way
in which that infinite is seen in the
world so you you honor the saints who
manifests to you the highest mode of
being the hotter clothes you know the
highest mode of love of being in
communion with God and you also honor
the the sacred places the sacred sacred
things which help you participate in
that mode to me that's the best way to
do it so that you don't because when you
oppose when you oppose worship complete
when you make worship so high that you
have to be neutral towards everything
else in the world it comes back yes it
comes back without your will and you you
end up doing things that you're not
aware of realize it's like I always tell
evangelicals who tell me that the only
worship God and you know you don't give
honor to anything else and I'm like why
what is this when you in church when
someone sings a good song how is it that
that happens like
you can understand what you're doing
like you also understand that you're not
aware of what you're doing because is
that the right reason to honor someone
is because they sang well there may be
better reasons to honor someone besides
that they performed well anyways so it's
like if you have to it's better to be
aware of it and to give proper honor to
the different levels and yes and then do
it and they don't exist
do it anyway you're absolutely right and
so so we go again yeah I do it anyway so
we go back again to like a uniting of
all the parts yeah they do exist this is
reality this is life this is being a
human being everything is it's about you
know all these things if you approach
them in communion rather than rejection
or rather than idolatry then you have a
integrated system let's just say I could
probably get slapped on there is but
it's it's totally understandable like it
is that is what that structure is what a
real integrated look like in the world
to like a company a family you know all
of these things have to have that
balance between between the highest
thing that unites us and the the
participation of all the parts within
that that higher thing so yeah I let's
just say integrated system is a fractal
way of the bigger pattern there you go
alright I don't know if there's
something else cuz we've been going for
a while for about an hour and a half so
I don't know if there's something else
that you wanted to do you talk about
okay there's one last thing I think I'd
like to bring up so I think it's really
interesting and it's a big problem we're
having now in society and you're I can't
I was gonna watch it another again the
propaganda video where you're saying the
feminine qualities are just as important
as the masculine qualities and for some
reason in society we've decided and I
think it's because of rationality I
think because rationality is essentially
a
masculine structure and that's what we
Revere that we've also put in the
highest value know the highest
attributes into that and lower to the
feminine and then part of what you're
talking about is you know bringing the
feminine up to where it needs to be and
on par with the masculine
it's about correct I think I think that
I think that a way to to to understand
it is how can I say this it's it's is
that the the absolute necessity of the
feminine for the world to exist that you
have there is no way to avoid it
and so it's to bring the the problem
with saying higher yeah I know in in a
hierarchical structure yeah in a way the
the the feminine is the is the opposite
of the the hierarchical structure and so
and so it's if that's the problem when
we want say we want to make women equal
to men it's like if you do that then
you're already negating the power of the
of the the feminine which is our the
question the power of the space the
power of of the opening up of Middle
East and so and so it's not that I want
to make women you know on the same level
as men but it's mostly that I want to
open up the space for us to be able to
perceive and to engage in the feminine
aspects of reality yeah but then on the
actual hierarchy there the each rung of
the hierarchy let's say has feminine and
masculine for everything to exist it has
to and so that's why a lot of people who
look at feminine symbolism very simply
they they they'll say like you know man
above women below and you see that in in
some of the representations that are
used but it's like yeah but it's like
what's a queen then you know there is at
every level there is a a coupling you
can say at every level of the of the
social hierarchy of the ontological K
there's a coupling between the
potentiality or the opening of the space
and then the manifesting or the making
public or making visible or what
ever you know of that space too so it's
always it's always happens in terms of a
coupling and so what I would I want like
but I think what you said is right is
the problem with the modern world is
that it's actually very very masculine
and a lot of the a lot of the feminism
that we've seen is a is a weird
masculine caricature like if I could ask
you that it's not an actual it's not an
actual let's say glorification of the
feminine you know but the problem about
it is it's really hard to talk about
this because of the mists mysterious
aspect of what the feminine is so
there's there's a way in which I always
eyeball I always kind of hesitate to
talk about it too much because but even
by explaining it your your your D
there's a de sac realization which is
happening in the very mode of explaining
the feminine too much you don't want to
explain it because that's not it's a
question it's a it's a it's the very
space it's the opening so how do you if
you try to explain it too much and your
your your denaturing it I don't know if
that makes sense it does make sense and
so it's a weird it's a weird it's a
weird game that I've been engaged in
which is to try to point at it to try to
talk about it a little bit to give
images to give suggestion without
without denaturing something it does
make sense would you say that is that in
in in orthodoxy it's the Sophia is that
correct I mean yeah that's a big problem
the host of because we had that very
problem at the beginning of this entry
which is that some theologians tried to
talk about Sophia and the relationship
between Sophia and and the Virgin and
the mother of God and pushed it very far
in terms of theological pronouncement to
a point where they were talking about
the mother of God and Sophia like
talking about the mother God as an
incarnation of Sophia you know in very
difficult ways which which which was got
slapped by the church like the the
church slapping said no this is
you can't it's not proper it's not a
proper way to talk about God and a
proper way to talk about it and I think
I mentioned it recently in a video where
there are some things which are true but
they become untrue when you say them and
and they they have to remain unsaid and
I think one of the problems that
sociology ran into is exactly that
problem which is they're trying to
express something which should not be
expressed which should remain in in the
unsaid they're trying to they're trying
to explain it rationally the time to
rationally exactly they're trying to
extract explains something which is by
its very nature is the opening up of the
rational space which is opening up of
the space of the world so your your
denaturing it by talking about it does
make sense yeah so it's a it's a so the
feminine is a problem in that sense
because you want to sometimes I was like
I want to say certain things and I'm
like but I'm not helping it's like I'm
not helping by by going to too far in
the in the in the pronouncements you
know well I think I think one thing I
got out of it though that I did find
helpful is just keep in mind that value
of the feminine mmm-hmm you know that
that don't dismiss it it is a value and
another thing that's interesting is all
human beings have elements of both yeah
sure so in the way that it's presented
like in same access and a lot of the
fathers is that that that Christ in a
way United both and transcended both you
know and so Christ is a is is ultimately
androgynous in that in that sense yeah
but you you know that yeah so there is I
always tell people that there is a
manner in which I you know the church is
feminine hi when I pray I'm acting in a
feminine manner when I and so there's
there's there's this whole idea that but
it yeah but it also it also we always we
also have to see the mass in the
feminine within their specific spheres
and that's what that's what it's so hard
people just muddle everything together
you know and I've seen this too it's
like
let's say the argument that I use which
is that we're all feminine in relate in
in in certain aspects of us then they'll
say well there there you go we could
we're all feminine rawmaster engenders
in the manner in which I am a man in the
world then then I in that mode then I am
not feminine I am masculine but in the
manner in which I am the church and I am
a supplicant in the manner which I am I
am worshipping then I will embody also
all of that I try to embody all of that
which is which the Virgin embodies but
in terms of you know in terms but i but
I marry a woman because in that mode of
my viola my physical self of the social
presentation of myself that I am I mean
you know it's like twist it so it's like
there is no just because we can see that
femininity masculinity exists in all
aspects and all levels of reality does
it mean that it's confused it's not
confused it's not anything goes and it's
not whatever you want it's yeah exactly
and and Phaedra Swede say that supplying
the rational knife to something that
shouldn't be cut up mm-hmm
and that's a big actually that's a big
component of the art of motorcycle
maintenance that's how he characterizes
cutting things up or ashley's with the
rational life that's I will I will debt
I'll have to read the Zen and it's a
great book and it's two of them now it's
easier for me oh there's a really good
audio book I mean actually someone has
put it online and I can I can send you a
link to that it's the voice actors
fantastic it's good it's such a pleasure
to listen to I have way more time for
audiobooks because I'm carving the
actual reading books is very limited I
do but you just have to keep it to what
you really need to read all right so I
think I think I think we should wrap
this up and I and I and I yeah I really
appreciate I really appreciated your
channel I've appreciated watching the
videos where you're trying to kind of
piece them together I can feel the
authenticity in your desire to kind of
figure things out and and we shouldn't
keep
tabs on on each other I'll try to to
kind of keep an eye on what you're doing
in okay well thank you and I will
certainly do the same for you and thank
you so much for inviting me on your
channel and it won one last thing I'd
like to say is I love your introduction
I I think I bet you're painting correct
of Genesis it's not mine no it's a it's
a traditional it's a it's a
traditionally from a German missile it's
a it's a representation of the six days
of creation yeah I look at you it's
incredible and and it's funny you know
that that opening overture the eastern
yeah so Shahrazad has always been my
number one favorite piece of music so
when I heard that I was like aha that's
wonderful
it's also like it's people don't realize
that it's that it's actually like a
resurrection like you that mm-hmm first
part because it's starting right away at
Easter ascending part at the end of the
clip it's that's that's like the
resurrect that's the Easter Easter
moment so and so it's like to me that's
what's going on but also in the image of
creation people like I mean I'm giving
my secrets away here but thank you you
know the awakening of ease that's yeah
yeah so that to me is also like I said
it's one of the things that I'm trying
to do we're talking about too much
you're doing it explicitly or turning
around it and and and pointing and
talking and so yeah makes sense well
thank you so much Jonathan this has been
such a treat and I've you know I've
learned a lot today I continue to learn
from you and thank you all right and I
and I also wish you the best on your own
personal journey I'll be I'll be looking
forward to seeing where it leads you yes
thank you very much all right okay take
care
if you enjoy the symbolic world content
there's a lot of things you can do to
help us out if you're not subscribed
please do go ahead and share this to all
your friends if you can get involved in
the discussion we have a Facebook group
in which people
can talk about these subjects I will put
all those links in the description and
also if you can please support us
financially by going to my website
www.ihaveaspergers.webs.com